alright guys bang bang I'm here with
Jared we got a whole bunch of stuff to
talk about this is part two if you will
of a interview series with finance
charity there's a whole bunch of stuff
that they're working on I think is
really important to kind of highlight
and showcase so what they sort are
coming to do this absolutely thank you
for having me really happy to be here
alright let's start with your background
and kind of how you will you got into
crypto and then we'll get into a we
guess you know with finance yeah
absolutely so my whole life I always
wanted to be a teacher that was my
passion I enjoyed teaching people I
enjoyed the thrill of helping people
make those connections and understand
something that they previously couldn't
and you know I went through school with
that ambition started going into college
as a mathematics major found that it
wasn't exactly the direction I wanted to
go in for a couple reasons one being it
wasn't exactly lucrative and that said I
I ended up making a major pivot in my
life I switched over to a business major
and at the same time I started in my
sales career in tech and I went through
got my business marketing degree and I
really found that like I made a
connection between being able to teach
people about technology something that
might not have been easily comprehended
prior because I'm a tech nerd at heart
I'm geeky I'm a gamer I love all aspects
of Technology so to be able to help
people to understand it and something
truly fascinating to me so as I kind of
climb through the ladder I worked at
multiple tech startups throughout the
Silicon Valley I'm in different
marketing and sales capacities and sales
training really is what kind of was most
appealing to me beyond all of that I
started to learn cryptocurrency in about
2015 and I really I saw you know that
cryptocurrency provided something that
we didn't have and where we work with
humans were one of the few things in
this world that are unpredictable
most other things are not random by
nature human behavior is and what I
loved about blockchain was was it
eliminated that random you
nature I mean there's always that
teetering point of trust as to when
somebody's gonna behave in one direction
or the other and what I loved about
blockchain was was it eliminated that
and no longer did you have a brand of
trust but you had a system of trust and
I just seeing what blockchain can do and
seeing what type of news is out there
and what type of news could be out there
was some of the positive impacts that we
don't hear about is what really fueled
my fire to get more engaged in this
space got it what um when you first saw
crypto and Bitcoin what kind of caught
your attention what was that thing that
pulled you down the rabbit hole so I if
I if anyone really says is the first
time they heard about Bitcoin is not
related to the money aspect of it I mean
there's always that component
I mean people operate on incentive and
my incentive as many others were was wow
what is this asset that otherwise is
making people rich and does that
intrigue and that was my initial kind of
interest to it once I drove a little bit
deeper though I found like it wasn't
necessarily just the opportunity to make
money it was the underlying technology
and it I found it difficult for myself
to learn and interpret the technology by
my own so that's why you know if I run
into those situations where I can't
understand something I dedicate an hour
a day to try to learn more about it
little by little until I get that click
and once I have that I'm usually just
full-on bored
yeah I think it's Parker Lewis from
Unchained Capital who says came for the
money but stayed for the money right
meaning that came for like the personal
financial gain and then quickly get
thrown down the rabbit hole like what is
money why is it important you know yadda
yadda and then all of a sudden you
realize hey this is actually a really
really big deal and so people stick
around for the money
absolutely it's like a financial gain
very cool so let's talk about kind of
blockchain technology and charity I know
some that you're passionate about and
something you for spending more and more
time on maybe just help us understand
like what are the problems in the
traditional philanthropic area that you
think that blockchain technologies can
solve and with then we can get into some
of the specific examples definitely so
you know we've all heard the stories
about corruption and charity and
whenever there's something good or
something with great power I feel that
corruption
always follows and we have that
demonstration in crypto we've seen it
with AI cos we've seen all of these
things that kind of raised out of it and
unfortunately humans are creatures that
kind of flocked in negative media
it's our fear or flight mechanism when
we see something that otherwise can
challenge us or otherwise it's gonna be
you know could be painful we want to
learn about it so otherwise we don't
fall victim to it unfortunately it's our
Achilles heel and with charity
specifically I'll give an example of the
Red Cross in Haiti there was about 500
million dollars of donations 125 million
dollars was dedicated to overhead
expenses which is a pretty significant
amount when you think about it it really
shouldn't take that much effort to give
somebody money you what goes into
overhead expenses you know there's gonna
be salaries there's gonna be of course
the transfer agents there's a number of
things that goes into it but to say that
125 million dollars is required to get
from point A to point B I I know a lot
that could have been done with 125
million dollars but if you go even a
little bit further down that rabbit hole
of the remaining three hundred and
seventy five million dollars there was
only six houses that were reconstructed
and what yes and that was actually
posted online I believe the Wall Street
Journal it made a post about that Wow so
there's a lot of unsolved or kind of
unknown as to what happened in that
catastrophe specifically like if there's
five hundred million dollars they unless
they're only building six mansions
there's obviously a lot that could have
been done with that and where blockchain
really can kind of help with this is is
if you hand your money to Red Cross as
we gave the example of you had a hundred
dollars how much ends up and then
beneficiaries hands and it's roughly
about twenty dollars with blockchain and
we at Finance of what we're really
trying to do is is not only empower
people with those funds we create the
wallets on their behalf we put the money
directly into that wallet so there's
end-to-end transparency but then we take
it a step further and we educate on how
to access those funds how to convert it
to fiat in their local currencies and
that's really the fascinating part is is
that the people in these communities
they haven't even had computers they
haven't had internet and now they're
getting cell phones and they're getting
cryptocurrency wallets so it's
it's that leapfrog effect in which they
are skipping an entire generation of
Technology yeah so for those that didn't
listen to the first part with uh with
Helen from - charity essentially what
you guys are doing is you're creating
wallets you're handing them to people
I'll say in need right because it could
be a whole bunch of different reasons as
to why they're getting this they are the
recipients of the philanthropic
contributions that someone somewhere
else is is contributing and part of the
value here is finance charities covering
100 percent of the operational curbs
re-buy Nance is covering 100 percent of
the operational cost of Finance charity
so every dollar or every B&B every
Bitcoin whatever you contribute through
by name is charity 100 percent of that
is being received by one of those people
in need and so rather than that hundred
dollars only twenty percent twenty
dollars makes it to the final recipient
here a hundred dollars makes it and then
obviously using blockchain and digital
wallets the contributor can actually
track and know exactly where their money
went which is a kind of a really big
thing I think from a confident
standpoint of just I want to understand
that I'm making an impact now that I can
track it I have to say have higher
degree of confidence and hopefully that
will actually lead to more contributions
from people absolutely and you know as I
mentioned earlier blockchain is
excellent and excellent means of
eliminating that trust factor but
there's always going to be some port of
some part of human interaction that's
required in this process and I think at
that point the by Nantz name really
helps with that knowing that you know
you're working with one of the major
companies in the blockchain space and if
you were ever to trust somebody with
that last mile transition I I don't see
a better name than finance to be able to
help with that yeah and another thing
that I think it's pretty interesting
here is I think it's alex Gladstein the
chief strategy officer from the human
rights foundation has said to me he goes
look part of the reason why bitcoin
specifics what he was talking about but
just I think crypto even in general can
have such an impact on philanthropic aid
is a lot of times when you go and you
give the money to an organization that
you're talking about there's just
overhead costs but what he wanted to
really highlight was there's a lot of
corruption
occurs as well so when you donate money
somewhere they usually put it into some
sort of government bank account there's
usually you know what I'll put in air
quotes a tax by somebody somewhere
whether it's the leader of that country
or that local region or the owner of the
bank or whatever there's money that kind
of gets taken out and then it goes
through it like a waterfall right
there's a bunch of money in taxes and
all the stuff that occurs and you end up
getting a very low percentage right in
some cases twenty percent a little bit
higher a little bit lower it's the end
recipient and so his whole thing was
transparency is important for the
contributor but also I think what he was
really excited about was the ability to
circumvent potential points of failure
or potential points of corruption so now
all of a sudden you're not giving the
money to the government of a local
country or a local region you're giving
it directly to the recipient and so
you're actually reducing the incentive
for a nefarious actor to do something
right they they literally cannot do that
because now a contributor can directly
give to the recipient which i think is a
really powerful thing that if you're not
aware of how some of this works you just
you don't know the problem right but
once you understand a problem then the
solution becomes pretty obvious and it's
actually pretty exciting absolutely and
you hit the nail on the head the less
hands that are in the bucket so to speak
the less opportunity there is for a grab
and when there's that that's when you
have the opportunity to do something
really pure and yeah it's very
infrequent that you have an opportunity
where without going to Africa and
handing somebody a hundred-dollar bill
that's the closest of an equivalent that
you could get to this amount of
transparency yeah well what do you think
so you mentioned that some of these
people that are on the receiving end of
the philanthropic efforts right they've
never had a computer before they've
never had internet access all the stuff
and now they're getting mobile devices
Internet connectivity etc I think
there's a lot of people who would say
look how are these people gonna go from
I don't have internet access I don't
have connectivity to now I'm going to be
using crypto currencies and digital
wallets right a lot of folks in the
United States for example don't know how
digital wallets work they don't have
cryptocurrency works how do you think
about you know the education process and
kind of how those individuals who are
just now getting connectivity can kind
of leapfrog some of the folks who have
had it
a connectivity in the developed world
for a long time so it's if you think
about it this way there's like I
mentioned everybody has their
motivations everybody's incentivized by
certain things and if I were to go
door-to-door knocking on people's doors
trying to educate them on Bitcoin I'd be
treated just as though I was some sort
of religious and evangelist and get a
lot of doors close to my face because
they don't have the need for it but when
you go into a situation where there's
there's a demand or there's just a need
and Helen spoke about this just recently
was the bottom billion and those
individuals specifically will in my
belief be the main drivers of Bitcoin
adoption because at this point there's
nothing more of a drive than hunger or
just those basic needs I mean Mozilla
outlined it very well in which there's
you know your hierarchy of needs and if
one of those aren't being met that being
you know your food your security or just
your general health and hygiene you're
at a point where the demand is now much
higher and I mean the balance of supply
and demand if somebody needs it
desperately it would be amazing to think
what the human body or what the human
mind is capable of in those situations
and if you have no choice if it's
whether or not I'm gonna have dinner for
my family tonight or if I'm gonna have
sanitary pads or not I'm going to learn
what it's what is necessary I have a
great amount of incentive of survival
and for that reason I think that's going
to be the driver of Bitcoin and just
crypto adoption in general is just that
general demand or that absolute need to
survive yeah it's very similar to what
happened with mobile banking in general
across a number of nations in Africa for
example but elsewhere where it's almost
like they have no preconceived notions
they have no kind of allegiances to
certain technologies or mechanisms that
interact with the financial system
everything's cash right and so now all
of a sudden what they're able to do is
they're able to leapfrog because the
very first time that they ever deal with
quote/unquote mobile banking it happens
just to be better than the United States
right right
there's no kind of legacy technology
there etc which which i think is
exciting the other question is
I get okay by an answer or some other
group will create a digital wallet give
it to somebody now a contributor can
give currency to that end recipient how
does that end recipient use the
cryptocurrency right it's a component of
I've got a digital wallet maybe I can
figure out how to send it to somebody
else but what about with merchants and
kind of merchants adoption and all that
so with merchants adoption I think
that's one of the major bottlenecks to
just mass adoption and without add one
of my previous jobs was to train inside
sales personnel and what these inside
sales personnel would do is they would
call at least 500 small medium
businesses per day in efforts of selling
them a cost saving voice over IP system
and in their minds and in my mind and
anybody else who knows the full offering
that is a major savings of money you
could go from spending a hundred and
fifty dollars a month to spending $20.00
a month and there's an immediate demand
for that but the thing is is as soon as
you call somebody you're immediately at
a point of value transfer where they
aren't going to want to hear it until
you can get something out there fast
enough for them to be interested in
hearing more and they'll be quick to
hang up so to be able to penetrate a
market like small medium business and to
get the mass market interested in that
adoption is going to take a lot and
perhaps it might be something where they
have no other choice to do it maybe
we're put in an economic situation where
that's a mandate but just again in order
to really understand what will drive
that and what will get that to happen
you you really have to think like in
Africa is that going to be more of a
demand is that going to be another thing
just as in Venezuela you see paper paper
money littering the streets the Leapfrog
effect is either going to completely
swallow the existing currency system
what they're doing or we have another
thing in place and that's by Nancy ganda
in which will actually assist them in
converting from the crypto currency to
their local fiat and they'll be able to
then you do transactions as normal yeah
which is that that's the safeguard of it
hopefully and you know who knows what
will happen in five years we're in a
very young market but I could see it as
just as mentioning in those situations
of desperate need
where perhaps Fiat is less than
desirable then we're gonna have no
choice but then to adopt these
cryptocurrencies yeah what um what about
in the United States right I know a lot
of people who say hey look I believe
that there's you know billions of people
around the world that need help
everything from the Australian
brushfires to countries in Africa etc
but I want to help here in the United
States I think part of kind of your
focus with finances is here domestically
like how are you guys thinking about
various charities and philanthropic
efforts here at home in the kind of
Western world yeah and that's a very
good point that you bring up and I read
a shocking study that only 80 to 90
percent of Americans actually end up
traveling outside of the United States
we're a very and eccentric culture in
which there's not really so much of a
need to go out but I personally would
say that there is a need and as such
given that we don't get a ton of outside
cultural experiences I mean you may as
well put one of the the hungry
children's commercials with a Sarah
McLaughlin commercial behind it and
that's going to be I mean everybody at
least knows that these things are
happening outside the United States and
there's a great propensity to help and
it's also a very cost effective way to
help outside of the United States but I
think you're absolutely right in which
there is a demand there's a need to
really drive some of these fill and trap
philanthropic efforts in the United
States those being I mean the there were
fires in California there's a major
homelessness crisis the opioid crisis
there are many ways that we can help
closer to home and that's actually one
of the main reasons that I'm coming on
with finance is to really Drive those
initiatives to get close to home because
if you think about it I'd slightly
alluded earlier that people have flocked
to this negative attention regarding
Bitcoin about cryptocurrency and most
people think bitcoin is blockchain and
one in actuality there's much more to it
so to get people to really not be afraid
and I mean if you ask anybody about
Bitcoin who hasn't really involved
they're like oh I know people who lost
money in that or I know people who lost
their mortgages and that the biggest
striking emotions that I mean the
thought of losing a home can strike
anybody in the heart and that's what
people are going to remember there
remember how something made them feel so
in other words of what my thoughts are
is that focusing on us philanthropy
efforts is what's going to drive some
additional media towards Bitcoin in the
way that it needs to or towards
blockchain in the way that it needs to
to be able to demonstrate that there's
some pure benevolent capacities of
blockchain and I believe that if we can
get some real impacts and we're working
with a number of foundations to try to
pilot this opportunity the the Gleason
Foundation is one we're also working in
communications with Make A Wish
Foundation
the thing that we run into is is that we
we have a mission to uphold and that
mission is is that the money goes
directly into the hands of the end
beneficiaries and so what we need is is
we need partners we need partners that
are willing to basically shake hands
with us and allow us to take lead and
communicating directly with the end
beneficiaries helping them in the
conversion of from you know crypto to
Fiat will facilitate the entire process
in fact will sponsor the entire process
and handle all development costs but we
need somebody who can come into this as
a mutual partner and drive that same
initiative and ensure that the end
beneficiaries receive 100% of the
donation not ninety percent ninety five
or even ninety nine for that matter but
100 percent of it yeah and I guess part
of that is the mechanism is the same as
it would be in other countries where you
would give the digital wallet to the
end-user and then people could track the
funds etc correct got it and then what
would be the role of whether it's Make A
Wish or Gleason Foundation or any other
nonprofit like how would they help
facilitate or what would their role be
in that partnership their role in that
partnership would be connecting us with
the end beneficiaries we ultimately will
if you go to buy Nance not charity
you'll see a list of charities and a
list of projects most of those projects
are currently in Uganda what we would
end up doing then is creating a wallet
one dedicated wallet in which people can
send their donations to and with that we
would have a smart contractor or a code
in place that would then divide and
distribute to the end beneficiaries of
that project directly and I was speaking
with somebody last night who sadly their
wife has had ALS and is bedridden they
were in a situation where and if you've
heard about the Gleason Foundation or
heard about Leeson story which you can
stream it on Prime it's it's
absolutely beautiful yet devastating
story they waited a very long time
before they could even get a device that
allowed their wife to communicate in
which they if once ALS really takes
effect you lose all bodily control
including the ability to speak there are
devices that you can use that you you
literally use your eyes to be able to
speak and communicate again and the
worst part about that disease is is that
you're fully cognizant you're fully
aware of everything around but you're
trapped in your body and unable to speak
so those initiatives in itself if we
were to create something with the
Gleason Foundation we would work to say
okay and this you know the people that
have been on the bottom of this list the
people that have been waiting the
longest if there's a hundred of them if
the device is $15,000 we'll slowly stack
each of those accounts until they're at
that threshold that they're able to
actually purchase one of those devices
and that's where we really want to make
these success stories and you know
there's there's different tax
liabilities and things of that but we
try to make this an end-to-end solution
we have consultants that are helping us
with that process it's really a white
glove so it's not like we just set this
up and we end it we want to create these
success stories and we want to drive the
success of these foundations as a
partner a mutual partner for sure how
much of this is technology based in
terms of the technology is a kind of a
an advantageous component versus it's
more of just somebody saying hey this is
important and we're gonna put you know
warm bodies against it that are smart
that are passionate about this and we
can solve it that way so the initial
part of it is really the relationship
and that's where I'm coming in is to to
try to drive the relationships in the
United States with charities and
understanding and comprehending
blockchain once you overcome that
threshold and I'm sure you can relate
speaking of people it's like as soon as
you mentioned the word crypto I mean I I
wish I knew the person that is invented
the word crypto because I'd slap them in
the face and said what a terrible name
for such a magnificent technology I mean
it's in it in itself rude is cryptic and
crypto you think death you seem to think
something horrible if you mentioned the
word crypto in any type of business
interaction your credibility goes from
100 to 50 and immediately you're up
against a wall of barriers of how you're
overcoming why are using crypto to do
something like this because immediately
again people affiliate crypto to
negativity
that'd be child pornography whether that
be the dark web or anything else so one
I'd say the biggest barrier with a human
interaction the warm body aspect of it
is is the proof showing people that
blockchain is a true solution to this
and once you overcome that the
technology takes over and that's the
best thing about blockchain in my
opinion is is that it's all code and
it's trustless in which once the code is
implemented it's just a computer
following a set amount of instructions
so the main part of it the onboarding
once that's done which is you know a bit
of a lengthy process but still isn't as
necessary the rest of it is kind of
automated and autonomous in which the
finances marketing finance charity
foundations marketing and the marketing
of the partner is what will continue to
drive that as well as the influencers
that we partner with to drive focus
towards these initiatives yeah
what um would have been the channels
that you think of they're most effective
in terms of getting the word out on the
contribution side right getting people
aware of the projects that finance is
working on and kind of why they should
be contributing to so it's funny because
you know you and myself both are very
active in the crypto space and how long
ago was it that you learned about
finance charity I think when they first
announced it I think it was around the
maybe year and a half ago okay when they
announced either was the listing fees
were all gonna get donated or it was the
creation of the listing fees right right
and that was the big announcement
finance stated that all their listing
fees whatever that range was would go
directly to charity beyond that and you
heard much as to their efforts or the
amount of money that they raised I cheat
because I spent a lot of time with the
executive team in Singapore about uh
maybe a year ago two years ago whatever
it was and they can't give me a full
rundown so that doesn't really count
okay you're unfortunately passing my
[ __ ] test with flying colors and the
point I'm trying to make it's uh really
not many people have heard about it and
it disappointed me being an active
participant in the blockchain space to
not have heard about some of the success
I mean five million I raised and you
know the six months that they had done
so is absolutely magnificent so when I
had heard that I immediately thought wow
this is struggling people should be
hearing about this and not just people
in the crypto
but what about an opportunity for people
to hear about the crypto community in a
positive light versus a negative light
so what I would say right now is is the
channel that has been effective is
social media it has worked it's helped
but my approach in coming into this is
is to make more exposure to work with
the people that have influence in the
space and gamify this make it fun get
people I mean there's a lot of social
media campaigns that can otherwise
generate more revenue or more donations
should I say and I think that there's a
lot of room for growth and a lot of room
for partnership and what I will
encourage anybody who is interested in
the charity space and I could tell a
quick story for sure I am I came into
the space about a year and a half ago
and Anthony if you remember I talked to
you I said you know I want to be in this
space how can I participate what things
are necessary and I had a vision I know
I mean I could do marketing I can do PR
I can do all of this and for about a
year and a half I made ends meet and my
business was successful I got clients
and there was something that was missing
and I felt okay I can continue to engage
with them as this ecosystem but what is
it in my life that's really gonna make a
difference and on the side of all this I
run a nonprofit preschool chain where we
teach mindfulness and meditation to
children and their families and that was
very fulfilling to me it was my first
dabble into kind of a bit of
philanthropy and it wasn't until just
about three months ago I was on a panel
with Joanie of the finance charity
foundation and it was the first time
that I had heard of all of the great
things that they were doing and I told
her after the fact I said I am so
impressed with what you're doing but I'm
so disappointed that I haven't heard
about it sooner what are your efforts
and what have you done and they they
said that they had difficulties getting
exposure because journalists didn't want
to necessarily write about it because it
wasn't gonna drive the price of Bitcoin
and that goes back to the ulterior
motive of what is it that's really gonna
impact it and it made me you know it
broke my heart I said look I want to
help I will not charge you I will do
whatever I can and within just weeks we
got podcast speaking opportunities we're
getting featured in major news our news
releases and it was all of those things
at that point that they said okay we
want to work with you more and at that
point it kind of
converted to less of a me just doing
these pro bono efforts to really being a
strategic partner and it just took a
little bit of effort a couple of months
and now my life is completely pivoted in
a way where my entire focus is gonna be
focused towards these philanthropy
efforts so I would implore anybody who
has a similar feeling and their day-in
day-out of what is at the end of this
road to think about what is it that
would really be a memory of them and
it's as you mentioned yesterday I forget
who you quoted about you know what will
people remember you for when you die or
anything of that I mean we never know
how long we have yeah and that's where
my focus is now and so part of this I
think when people here by Nantz charity
I think they immediately go to oh
there's B&B and all the stuff but my
understanding is you guys are completely
agnostic to which asset people
contribute in and and really are trying
to drive the end impact not so much
worried about it being you know
exclusively tied to by an answer or B&B
token etc correct correct at this point
you can do BTC you can do a theory room
you can do B&B it depends on the project
as well but it doesn't mean that other
currencies can't be supported if you're
a bi Nance toka
area if you're on the by Nance exchange
the facilitation of it is relatively
simple I'll give an example I've been
working with Dan simmerman of the iota
Foundation and they also are working in
the philanthropy space very heavily so
there was an immediate synergy and
that's what I love about this space is
that if you have similar Minds you can
make some amazing things happen and when
it comes to philanthropy it's such an
immediate connection with somebody in
which you know that you both have only
the best intentions the most and the
purest of intent in mind and he said I
one iota to be able to you know be one
of these transactions and iota is a
felis transaction and there's no fees in
iota which is even more Puritan and in
itself it was a matter of an
introduction to their team and they're
working on seeing what can happen with
that facilitation and what can happen
with that integration and it's that
simple so any crypto projects out there
that want to be a bigger part of this
absolutely reach out and we can work on
that for sure what um what are you most
excited about kind of over the next five
years when it comes to abide a charity
or just the
kind of philanthropic industry in
general when it comes to crypto I'm most
excited about just the massive potential
of it I mean if you think of it in this
analogy the tip of the iceberg right you
can only see so much that's happened but
truly what's happened thus far has been
it's been strong but there's so much
potential we haven't even started in the
United States yet we just now are
starting so in the next five years what
my vision is is I want the crypto
community to band together and be a
voice that's heard and imagine a tragedy
whether it be a mass shooting some sort
of disaster relief or anything of that
and one of the major donation donating
parties being the crypto community not
by Nance
but the crypto community generating X
million dollars for a cause that in my
opinion is what's going to drive the
adoption of cryptocurrency and that's
what's gonna drive people to think I
want to learn a little bit more about
that maybe they won't learn a little bit
right then and there but maybe this
would be enough for them to get their
first wallet or maybe it'll get that
just to be enough for them to watch a
video about what this is I mean there's
an education component that as soon as
the interest or the awareness starts
there's an adoption process and
hopefully by these initiatives we're
gonna be able to plant some of those
seeds which will over the next five
years grow into beautiful trees yeah
absolutely
are there any things you're concerned
about in terms of when it comes to
cryptic community and charity I am and
you know I've said before the crypto the
community it's it's a nerds paradise but
it's also you run into that effect where
you you get the mask behind the computer
and I've had and I'm sure you can attest
that I've had countless hackers from
overseas attempting to steal my bitcoins
and you lose that it's not like you're
you're stealing a wallet from somebody
in line you lose that face-to-face
interaction where now that isn't a
person that's just Bitcoin and you're
just taking Bitcoin from from a wallet
that you have no idea who that's tied to
so you lose some of that and I think
that's a lot of the fear that people
have about cryptocurrency so as I
mentioned earlier where there's
opportunity there comes corruption but I
believe that the mess the system that's
been built in place right now is as pure
as it can get
I I would only hope that over the coming
years that only purity comes into this
but I I know that there will be other
things that follow so I I do have fear
of there being corruption that could
occur what but we take every in it and
we take a valiant effort towards every
person that we vet every partner every
end beneficiary to ensure that it's only
going be going to be put towards the
benefits that we otherwise were
disclosing in the process for sure and
then what can people do at home in order
to participate or or kind of learn more
about what you guys are doing for one
follow us on Twitter follow us on social
media channels and keep I would say you
know the one thing just look at
blockchain for good projects it doesn't
take long to support them it doesn't
take long to circulate it and it's just
a matter of visibility perhaps a retweet
on something we'll get that to be
visible to somebody that might make a
hundred dollar donation Helen gave a
great example yesterday that they
created the pink care token in Africa
and Uganda specifically sanitary pads
don't really exist so imagine the impact
that that could have on a young woman's
life there's their social interaction
their behaviors the way that that molds
and the way that that makes it makes
them for a four dollar donation that's a
year's worth of sanitary pads so even
the smallest amount to make a real big
difference that said get engaged start
sharing these things and start helping
to promote that awareness and take part
of it
I mean action is one of the the biggest
things we can take and that's one of the
biggest ways we can make an impact is
just by making a slight contribution or
sharing and circulating absolutely where
can people find you on on the Internet
you can find me on LinkedIn you can find
me on Twitter big Linkedin guy yeah I am
I am I am and you know LinkedIn it's
more of a messaging platform than
anything for me but yeah you know you
can follow me on Twitter you can connect
with me on LinkedIn or you can reach out
to me via email my emails probably all
over the Internet at this point but if
you connect with me on LinkedIn just add
a note saying that you want to talk
about charity foundations or anything of
that and I'll be more likely to accept
and start a conversation absolutely just
don't try to sell me anything come on
you're training sales teams how how do
you hate on somebody else try this I
know it's so funny because when I
started inside sales and I started
training people and after I was hung up
on a couple thousand times I stopped
hanging up on telemarketers and even my
wife stopped hanging up on telemarketers
because she's like oh that could be my
husband or that yeah it's someone in
that same situation and you know you get
kind of just some of that empathy from
it it's it's funny but that's it I don't
like LinkedIn sales messages yeah I
don't answer LinkedIn sales messages or
the telemarketer so I don't have that
exactly that opportunity I phone feature
of silencing unknown callers is a
blessing and a curse you know absolutely
I've limited my distractions but I also
miss some important calls so for sure
let's grab it fired before we finish up
what do you think's most important
company in crypto other than by Nance
other than by hands you know if we're
thinking from a United States
perspective just in general I think that
I might get backlash from this yeah
especially from the passionate crypto
users but what I love about coinbase
specifically is is that they're not only
I mean they're a simple approach they
are the retail of crypto but what I like
what they've been doing is is that
they've been putting in an education
process as well so not only are people I
mean before when I signed up for
coinbase it's like entering your credit
card and it encourages you to do a
credit card it's faster transactions
everything else and there's a lot of
opportunity to lose some money in that
situation what I like that they're doing
now is the education component you're
learning about the assets that you're
investing into and you're actually
incentivized to learn about them so I
think that gamifying just the adoption
of crypto and the companies that are
doing exactly that are some of the
missing piece of this and helping people
to learn and understand because people
won't really trust what they don't
understand so what um what's the one
regulation or law that you would change
or improve if you could I would there's
a lot of them I went to Malta recently
and have you been to Malta or an
international conference recently I've
been to some international places but I
have not been to Malta so Malta I went
to their conference and it was easily
and no exaggerations 10 to 15 times
larger the exhibit floor had such a
great amount of innovation
and I feel that the United States
dampens and otherwise creates a barrier
to entry of innovation and we're gonna
get surpassed in that way in which all
of these innovative ideas if they have
to spend fifty thousand dollars in
attorney fees to be able to even get
that idea on the roadmap or to make it
legal it's that there's so many ideas
that just aren't happening and you can
see when you go to Malta and there's
just all these great projects and I was
actually there with the securities
attorney Josh Lawler so many of them had
such a great use case but their problem
was was that they're afraid of coming to
the United States when it's such a huge
market so to help them to come over
there's obviously a cost associated but
that barrier to entry in itself I think
that the regulations if there's a way to
be a little bit formas more permissive
or reconstruct the the token laws that
we have now the token tax the taxonomy
Act is a perfect example of it there are
things that need to happen our our laws
are a bit archaic and if they continue
to prevent us from growth the rest of
the world is just going to jump right
over us
yeah I think it's a fair point most
important book you've ever read Sun
Tzu's Art of War and it's the most
boring because I find that military
warfare and business if you change some
words here and there they're almost
identical it's and when you read that
think about it from a business stand and
some zoo is spot on in every aspect it's
a dry read but I a lot of my personal
like beliefs have been kind of built
from that foundation in terms of you
know it's an approach of truly
understanding an environment before you
jump into it you know and that's where a
lot of people lose money a bit point out
a crypto they jump into it before they
fully understand it but son zoo know
thyself know the enemy thousand battles
thousand victories you know probably you
know I don't sound too pretentious by
saying is most well-known quote but that
in itself if you know everything about
the environment you're going into you
know your competitors you know the
threats you know the risks you're
eliminating surprises in business is
only advantageous so absolutely aliens
believer I think you it's almost like
the Schrodinger's alien right
I don't know how to explain that another
way but it's a think that there's not
something out there in such an expansive
universe as naivety but there until we
find it people are gonna be naysayers so
I I think that you know until we can say
that we've explored every inch of the
galaxy which is never going to happen
there's no reason not to believe yeah
what um what do you think happens when
we find aliens you think that it's a
mass hysteria and everyone's freaking
out do you think people are like wow
it's really cool science breakthrough
what's the reaction you know there was a
a movie that really fascinated me I know
I hope that you remember the name of it
because I don't off the top of my head
it was I think was Julianne Moore or
someone of that but the premise of it
was was that aliens had came to the
world and they had different stations in
all the different countries one being
China one being the United States and it
showed how all the different cultures
reacted and how people misinterpreted
what what their motive was so
immediately you know they put up a
symbol and everybody tried to decipher
the symbol and they created a roundtable
of people that started talking about it
and the symbol was deciphered to be
either a weapon or a tool and China
thought that it was a weapon and China
immediately starts launching nukes at
them to try to fight them off whereas
everyone else is what I'll wrap it up
the premise of the story was was that
the aliens ultimately wanted the world
to Co have a coalition and create a
round table of people that were
effective at communicating and the
aliens wanted help the United Health the
world and they wanted to know that we
were capable of empathy and support and
love and compassion and that we would be
able to otherwise learn from them and in
their time of need
as they are they had starvation on the
or something of that that was on the
brink of you know their devastation that
they would be able to lean on us for
help
so at the end of it I think that you
know don't fear what you don't
understand instead maybe some intrigue
but at the same time don't be the person
underneath the Independence Day you know
explosion you know take an observation
from a fair distance and try to learn
but don't fear what's unknown yeah I I
think it's a very different perspective
than like the alien invaders that are
coming to kill us all like Mars Attacks
or something of that
or signs you know that's wonder we got
some compassion yes exactly hopefully
they're loving aliens at the end of the
day that would be very very good well
one question you have for me to finish
up uh what do you think needs to happen
in the charity space for people that
believe in trust I'm a huge believer
that people are much more empathetic and
helpful when they have real-world
experience and understanding and so the
most powerful thing you can do is you
can take somebody and have them
experience the pain somebody else has
right and pain not being hey you've got
to go be hungry or hey you've got to go
be homeless or you've got a you know go
and you know be in a place where there's
no clean water but if you can just
expose people to look there's this
problem right so whether that's through
you know kind of things that are as
simple as a movie or a book podcast
something like that or as complex as
actually physically taking somebody to
go and see it for themselves I think the
more that people are exposed to that and
realize kind of the challenges and
complexities other people's space it's
just more likely that they are willing
to participate in helping solve that
problem or improve somebody's life right
I think that's one of the big challenges
of charitable work is just how do you
get people to understand they the issues
and care about the issues right and so I
think you solve that by exposure big
questions always how do you do it but
right say the Internet makes it a little
bit easier and then if you can get
people to actually travel to wherever
the the area of impact is I think that
there's a you know solutions there as
well so are you ready for us to fly you
do you got into them yeah I would
definitely go to Uganda we're gonna talk
more about that I I have gone to to
Nigeria two three years ago and I
absolutely loved it yeah so I'd be down
for Uganda trip alright we're gonna talk
more about the two episodes they've got
me donating money and potentially going
to Uganda you guys work fast yeah
we've gotta close the deal whoa we've
got you absolutely alright well thank
you so much for coming to do Jared thank
you so much definitely gonna have to do
this again in the future as you guys
keep it going and making more progress
because I think the work you guys are
doing is super important and for those
that want to learn more they can go to a
by Nancy charity and see all the great
work that you and your colleagues are
doing fantastic absolutely thank you